cloud cover as we move right along uh i
think we do have to talk about the fact
that this storm has underperformed we
were kind of building it up thinking we
get upwards of a quarter of an inch of
rain i don't even think we're going to
get a tenth of an inch of rain we're not
completely done there will be these
storm clouds hanging around as you see
this blanket of cloud cover in our live
picture from the red rock resort way out
on the west side of town the lights of
this trip going to be some great
fireworks into a great view for the
fireworks officially 45 degrees 39 right
now for summerlin still some snow
falling and the winter storm warning is
still in effect until tomorrow afternoon
up on the mountain 46 for the strip in
green valley we have the new year's eve
temperatures coming up 45 right now for
spring mountain
for the sunrise mountain that is and
let's get you to nevada and beyond the
snow still falling up in reno near
tonopah ely for sure lincoln county
caliente you're just above the freezing
marks a little rain snow mix going on
cedar city you are at 30. over the hump
in front with the 42 laflin checking in
with the warm spot at 50. now we managed
to make it to 50 as the sun was out for
a good period of time yesterday before
there were a couple of sprinkles 52 is
what we're trying for for this afternoon
so let's go to tomorrow night at 8
o'clock it'll be 47 it'll feel like 42
and then the longer you're out the
colder it feels dropping to 44 at 10 p.m
feeling like 40. 42 at the stroke of
midnight will feel more like 38 in the
meantime there are more storms already
for the pacific northwest as if they
need more snow up there and there's
definitely been a lot of rain down in
southern california just not making it
over here into southern nevada
combination of very cold air very warm
air turned into some reported tornadoes
across the deep south and it may be a
messy new year's eve back east now right
now it's below zero in bismarck single
digits for minneapolis but 73 degrees in
the middle of new white new orleans so
where these co the cold air and the warm
air comes together that is definitely
going to be some stormy weather for us
scattered storms should be clearing out
overnight tonight 54 for the high on the
last day of the year
the official low for new year's day 36
and the afternoon high 46.